malheureusement à cause de cet
amendement de dernière minute quoi est
notre invité politique ce matin c'est
joël giraud bonjour je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être avec nous cette affaire
d'état chargé de la ruralité on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale qui représentait
ce matin par sébastien couratin bonjour
sébastien est journaliste à l'écho
républicain le groupe centre france on
commence à pas en parlant de la crise
sanitaire
joël giraud je sais que la france rurale
est moins concerné que les zones
urbaines et qu'en conséquence les
mesures décidées peuvent parfois y avoir
été moins comprise
vous savez qu'il a dit ça c'est jean
castex lors du comité interministériel
au ruralité est ce que le confinement il
passe moins bien dans les zones rurales
écoutez il est vrai qu'au départ de la
crise des zones rurales avaient été dans
la première partie de gérer de
l'évolution de la pandémie avait été
moins touchés et il est vrai que les
mesures de confinement de ce fait
lorsqu'elles ont été prises ont été
moins bien acceptée c'est tout à fait
vrai cela étant le conseil quand même
terrible c'est que aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt dans les zones rurales comme un
développement qui est spectaculaire moi
je suis originaire des hautes-alpes qui
a été fait à dire malheureusement en
tête de tous les départements concernés
étaient élevés de près de 20% des taux
de positivité qui sont considérables
c'était le taux le plus élevé de france
maintenant c'est la savoie j'irai qui
est redevenue le premier département
donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui les choses
sont claires on a une situation
sanitaire qui est tiré cette fois
totalement dramatiques sur l'ensemble du
territoire donc les mesures si elles ont
été mal prise au début commence quand
même à être comprise parce qu'il n'y a
personne qui n'est pas quelqu'un dans sa
proximité immédiate famille ou autres
qui ne soient pas touchés donc voilà
quelques saisons au real soit plus
touchés parce que les mesures étaient
mal comprises mal accepté donc mal
appliquée je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
choses je pense qu'il ya eu surtout
énormément de touristes cette année dans
pas mal de zones qui étaient des zones
rurales et qu'à partir de là tout le
monde s'est senti un petit peu protégés
parce que quand vous êtes dans un espace
où vous avez une commune qui culmine à
quelque 1000 mètres d'altitude tout fête
de la rando vous pensez pas forcément
que dans un refuge de haute montagne la
promiscuité va être tels que vous allez
pouvoir
chopé un virus voilà je pense qu'il ya
eu un relâchement qui était lié au fait
qu'on retrouve une liberté notamment les
gens qui venaient des villes et qui
avait été contraint pendant quand même
c'est dur d'être contraint pendant des
mois dans des appartements qu'ils sont
petits ils se sont retrouvés en liberté
et voilà il ya aussi la rentrée scolaire
avec des particularités dans des régions
comme les miennes
on n'a que des enfants asthmatiques qui
viennent de la france entière et qui ont
peut-être aussi accélérer le processus
mais bon après je veux dire je ne suis
pas médecin je ne sais pas comment se
diffuse ce virus mais en tout état de
cause aujourd'hui la ruralité est aussi
concerné ça continue simplement est
souvent plus facile de vivre en ruralité
avec une pandémique de vivre en ville
parce que ça n'est pas la même chose de
téléphoner à son traiteurs bouchers
charcutiers unique et de récupérer un
plat que d'être en ville en train de
faire l'acteur né dans un hypermarché
voilà c'est plus vivable mais c'est
malheureusement dramatiquement en faire
au niveau du bilan des régions aussi
touchée que les autres maintenant et
j'ai d'ailleurs fait une vidéo spéciale
pour les zones rurales parce que je
trouve qu'il fallait faire il faut faire
plus attention maintenant dans nos zones
même si on a des espaces espace ne veut
pas dire non circulation d'un virus je
suis en ruralité
les mesures sont pas toujours comprises
y compris par les élus il ya plusieurs
maires ruraux qui ont pris des arrêtés
municipaux autorisant l'ouverture des
commerces non essentiel c'est le cas on
aurait l'air mon territoire
il yad'autres d'autres mères qui a créé
des plateformes de commerce en ligne
pour soutenir les mêmes commerces est ce
que les élus sont dans leur rôle ou est
ce qu'ils se substituent pas à celui de
l'état l'ours lorsqu'ils sont en train
de créer des plateformes ils sont
parfaitement dans leur rôle et
d'ailleurs nous les aidons jir très
clairement il y à des aides qui sont
proposées par l'état pour faire en sorte
qu'il y ait un relais soit à partir de
plateforme nationale soit à partir de
plateformes créées localement qui sont
quelquefois plus efficace parce qu'on
connaît mieux son territoire que on le
connait trés depuis paris donc sur ce
plan là ils sont plus que dans leur rôle
en revanche c'est vrai que là l'espèce
de guérilla qui avait eu lieu sur les
commerces à ouvrir ou pas ouvrir
ne prenez pas en compte on était
toujours sur ces chiffres anciens d'une
première pièce d'un premier épisode de
pandémie qui n'avait pas vraiment touché
la ruralité
bon maintenant je crois que c'est
arrêter ces velléités
thür ce n'est pas non plus une majorité
d'élus faut quand même le dire très
clairement il y en avait chez moi il ya
une dizaine de maires qui voulait
prendre des arrêtés qui finalement ils
ont retiré soit ne les ont pas pris
parce que ça n'était pas raisonnable au
regard du bilan sanitaire qui devenait
de plus en plus dramatique car ça quand
ils et les retire pas assez les
tribunaux administratifs qui casse les
décisions est-ce que ça abîme pas la
relation entre l'élu et l'est le préfet
je sais surtout jours sur requête du
préfet et écouter bon dans le couple
maire préfet je veux dire ça forcément
laissé des traces mais des traces qui
sont quand même peu importante parce que
sur les 33 mille communes concernées il
ya quand même eu un nombre d'arrêtés qui
ne dépassait pas les sens
donc bon on peut considérer que c'est
quand même relativement marginal je vais
dire peuvent échanger c'est un petit
coup de pouce à 10 mhz mais où on s'est
rendu compte que finalement poujadisme
et pandémie ne faisait pas bon ménage
c'est pour jadis pour vous ce qu'ont
fait ces mêmes jeux
je pense très sincèrement que oui en
dessous la pression je ne connaissant
pas les chiffres réels parce que
rappelez-vous sur la première période de
la pandémie
tous les soirs renvoyer les chiffres
montent et il y avait une espèce de
psychose est entre guillemets son
chiffre qui est arrivé bon là moi je
voyais les chiffres qui étaient des
chiffres nationaux ou départementaux qui
s'aggrave est de plus en plus il n'y
avait plus les relations peut-être qu'il
y avait auparavant permis au moment de
la forte crise mais mais oui je pense
qu'il ya un moment où il faut savoir
raison garder il faut être très très
raisonnable et souvent je regardais ce
qui se passait chez mes voisins puisque
je suis frontalier de l'italie et je
constatais que
le respect aussi des mesures barrières
dans des zones très rurales très
montagnarde et était nettement plus
important que chez nous donc je crois
que là aussi il fallait faisabilité des
français dans cette deuxième vague pour
vous je pense que tout le monde si
relâché parce que tout le monde a cru
que c'était derrière nous c'est voilà
moi le premier en fait je le dis
clairement on pensait pas forcément le
matin à prendre un masque en tendance
10h valencia j'oubliais il faut que je
revienne le chercher à la maison pour
aller faire les courses
mais on ne pensait pas forcément donc je
vois je je pense que dans le souci de
bien faire c'est à dire de se dire il
faut pas que mon unique commerces
ferment peut il faut pas que ma ma
coiffeuse ferme il faut pas voilà il y a
des gens qui sont laissés entraîner vers
quelque chose qui n'était pas
raisonnable et il ne fallait pas le
faire justement est-ce que c'est
raisonnable de ré ouvrir les commerces
peut-être en fin de mois au tout début
décembre
tout dépendra de l'évolution de la
pandémie moi je suis pas du tout deux
âges
j'attends calmement des décisions en
fonction de la réalité de ce qui se
passe sur le territoire national et
c'est vrai que je suis pas sûr
optimistes quand je vois les chiffres
qui continuent certes diminue
tendanciellement mais qui sont quand
même extrêmement élevé y compris dans un
département comme le mien où je rêverais
vous comprenez bien je suis né je suis
né là bas je rêverais de pouvoir dire le
8 décembre joue au tous les italiens
vient de faire du ski les stations sont
ouvertes chez toi mec c impossible voilà
c'est tout mais vous parlez vous parler
de la réalité du terrain et c'est vrai
que sébastien l'a rappelé jean castex
parle beaucoup des territoires du
dialogue avec les élus locaux pourquoi
vous n'avez pas suivi le sénat qui a
voté le fait que ce soit les préfets qui
décident de la réouverture des petits
commerces dans leur département en
fonction de la situation sanitaire
territoriales je pense que je pense que
ce serait complètement illisible ce
serait complètement illisibles sur un
territoire comme le nôtre on on est un
état plus centralisée que tous les
autres états européens pensent est vrai
que dans d'autres états européens il ya
décisions qui sont décisions régionales
parce que ces régions qui sont au
pouvoir plus que l'état souvent on ne
sait pas quel est le nom du premier
ministre dans un certain nombre de pays
on sait parfaitement qu'il est le nom de
son président de région bonté n'est pas
le cas en france donc une mesure est
complètement incomprise en france
regardez ce qui s'est passé sur le
premier épisode de la pandémie sur les
rayons où on pouvait circuler autres
quand on disait on il faut pas sortir de
la région il faut pas sortir du
département les gens comprenaient pas
pourquoi un km 10 km il n'avait pas une
dérogation
tant qu'on est dans un pays qui est
ainsi fait que s'il n'y a pas une règle
nationale qui est la territorialisation
des réservations des mesures ne
fonctionne pas chez nous lors surtout
pour une mesure sanitaire ou très
franchement le virus lui
ils s'en fichent complètement je veux
dire il se fiche des frontières se fiche
des frontières régionales il se fiche
des frontières départementales
donc soyons un peu raisonnable là dessus
et est malheureusement gérer continuera
à appliquer des mesures qui sont des
mesures certes stricte certes très
pénalisante pour l'économie
encore plus pour certaines territoire
que pour d'autres mais faisons en sorte
que ce bilan tragique ne se poursuivra
jusqu'à un dernier mot sur ces petits
commerces je vais le dire c'est vrai que
le gouvernement depuis trois ans un
promet le programme action coeur de
ville qui vise à redynamiser les centres
villes
est-ce que c'est pas contradictoire de
promouvoir action coeur de ville et de
fermer les petits commerces
non parce que l'action coeur de ville
n'est pas en a pas en soi prévu le
prends débit tant qu'action coeur de
ville comme zonage très particulier en
zone rurale pour avoir des avantages
fiscaux pour les autres non j'en ai pas
en train de les tuer on est entré au
contraire les soutenir financièrement
d'une manière nettement plus
spectaculaire que ce qu'ils avaient
encore dans la première vague
bon alors après celle envie de reprendre
qui va être difficile moi c'est là où je
suis je suis plus inquiet c'est à dire
que lorsque vous faites un métier
difficile restaurateurs c'est un métier
qui pas facile par exemple c'est un
métier où faut être vraiment
physiquement très présent et après l'
envie de reprendre
ça va moins être financier que lui
envient de repiquer je dirais dans ce
type de travail extrêmement compliqué
quand on ne sait pas si du jour au
lendemain on va pouvoir ou pas exercer
sa profession
là c'est complexe mais c'est moins
financier je crois que lui
toxicologiques sont des métiers qui sont
difficiles et c'est la catégorie
socioprofessionnelle que maintenant cela
le plus évoquons la part du monde rural
dans le plan de relance 1 200 milliards
5 milliards fléchés vers les territoires
ruraux représentent 80% des communes à
peu près 20% de la population est ce
qu'on n'est pas un peu en dessous de la
bonne jauge non on n'est pas en dessous
de la chose parce que après j'allais
dire tout est une question de façon dans
les territoires ruraux vont pouvoir
monter leurs projets 5 milliards c'est
l'âge où j'allais dire où on prend d'un
côté
les petites lignes par exemple
ferroviaire c'est un bon exemple je
crois où on a effectivement plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros fléchés
sur ces petites ligues et je pense
souvent un exemple mettre de l'argent
sur une ligne entre 9h et dijon qui est
une petite ligne c'est toute la ruralité
au pied du morvan pour autant mettre
aussi beaucoup d'argent sur paris
clermont ferrand et desservir corona
blement la gare de nevers
ça n'est pas comptée comme étant quelque
chose en faveur de la ruralité alors que
la réalité elle est bien là de la même
façon
j'allais dire vous avez à l'heure
actuelle vous avez des dotations dont
une dotation qui s'appelle à des cils
que tout le monde connaît bien ici sur
votre chaîne et notamment les
parlementaires qui nous écoutent et elle
est prévue pour des projets structurants
on a réaffirmé en va réaffirmer dans les
circulaires qu'elle n'est pas du tout
réservé aux grandes agglomérations
qu'elle est cumulable avec les dotations
pour les territoires ruraux
ça on ne compte pas bien sûr à 100% dans
la ruralité c'est quand même un milliard
et demi d'euros qui sont mis en plus sur
la table
tout simplement parce que ces projets
doivent aussi émané des territoires
ruraux alors la vraie question dans les
territoires ruraux pour moi c'est
toujours celle de l'ingénierie et
l'ingénierie c'est ce qui a été un peu
au coeur sur et du comité
interministériel ruralité de l'autre
jour quant à eux tenus vraiment mal gré
je dirais les difficultés sanitaires et
autres parce que l'ingénierie dans ces
petits territoires
c'est effectivement quelque chose de
compliqué et nous avons notamment pris
une mesure que l'on avait souhaité que
qui a débuté qui est daniel la baronne
au sein de de l'agenda rural avait
vraiment porter qui est celle de mettre
des volontaires territoriaux
d'administration c'est à dire 800 jeunes
qui sont des jeunes diplômés ces jeunes
diplômés à qui on dit
revenez quand vous aurez 5 ans
d'expérience 10 ans d'expérience qui
voudront se retrouve à la fin de leur
carrière chômeurs
en n'ayant jamais travaillé quoi eh bien
ces jeunes ils vont être embauchés et
mis à disposition des collectivités
territoriales sous leur tutelle bien
évidemment pour justement monter le
l'ingénierie de projets du plan de
relance
et ça c'est important parce que certes
il ya les mesures nationales avec l'
agence nationale de cohésion des
territoires qui va aider ces territoires
sur réquisition du préfet bon il y a
également des crédits d'ingénierie on en
a fait des marches et l'ingénierie pour
qu'il y ait des journées de chargés
d'études campus mettre à disposition des
territoires mais moi je crois plus à
l'immersion de jeunes sur un territoire
parce que d'abord ça démontre que la
jeunesse est en est un fer de lance de
ces politiques là j'avais mené salle
lorsque j'étais président du comité de
massif des alpes avec la région provence
alpes côte d'azur et les régions qui
n'était pas encore aux verts du rhône à
lui qui était ronald tout seul il savait
fort bien fonctionné
je crois que le plan de relance sera
d'autant plus mise en oeuvre qu'il y
aura de cette ingénierie de territoriale
de développer dans nos petits
territoires dans nos petites interco et
dans quelques fois quelques quelques
communes je vais le dire on va parler de
ce comité interministériel ou réalité on
se souvient qu'en septembre 2019 à
edouard philippe alors premier ministre
avait présenté son agenda rural y avait
180 une proposition on en est
aujourd'hui de la mise en place de ces
proportions
quand on est grosso modo à la moitié des
mesures qui ont été soit fait soit on va
dire
mises en chantier bon pour autant moi je
considère qu'une mesure les là pour
vivre elle n'est pas là simplement pour
dire ok on l'a fait c'est un peu comme
un qcm en disant je coche la case et
puis c'est terminé non il faut faire
vivre après ce que l'on met en place il
y avait des mesures
une mesure par exemple comme petites
villes de demain qui est une mesure
intéressante puisque c'est la
déclinaison d'action coeur de ville mais
pour les communes de 0 à 20 mille
habitants je dis bien de zéro parce
qu'on a fait sauter le plancher alors on
peut considérer qu'elle est faite parce
qu'on l'a lancée avec jacqueline
gourault à barentin pour autant elle
fait l'objet d'un suivi qui était suivi
permanent de façon à s'assurer que sur
les territoires
on touche bien là le coeur de cible et
je mexplique parce que bon on a voulu
avec jacqueline gourault qu'il y ait pas
de plancher pas de plancher ça veut dire
que une commune dès lors qu'elle est un
bourg centre qu'elle a des difficultés à
rentrer dans la logique de ce programme
si amy habitants qui les dix neuf mille
habitants bon et ça c'est effectivement
quelque chose que l'on suit j allais
dire de manière très précise
on a même autorisé les préfets à faire
des propositions de communes regroupées
au sein d'une intercommunale et souvent
je suis allé par exemple dans les
combrailles dans le puy de dôme
j'ai pas loin de la métropole de
clermont bat j'ai vu qu'il y avait dans
la combraille trois anciens chefs lieux
de canton qui avaient chacun leurs
spécificités leurs difficultés et qui
valait mieux une candidature groupée de
trois communes au sein d'une
intercommunale à j'ai l'exemple d'une
mesure qui certes est réalisé sur les
180 une mais qui reste gérée en chantier
d'ailleurs c'est sur six ans et il ya 3
milliards sur six ans dans cette affaire
là justement les élus s'interrogent par
rapport à ce dispositif
quels projets seront couverts pour quel
montant est ce que c'est cumulable avec
d'autres d'autres dispositifs
il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes dans les
campagnes écoutez moi chaque fois je
vais en voyage officiel en maintenant je
pense qu'on peut plus aller en voyage
officiel mais j'explique quelle est la
mesure où effectivement la mesure est
simple il ya déjà de l'ingénierie dédié
si vous êtes une
une commune qui a un problème notamment
de commerce de centre-ville ajout de
centre-bourg plus d'artisans qui ont
diffusé à s'installer
on paye là dedans par exemple des
managers de centre bourg qui permettent
justement de refaire ce lien lorsque
c'est un projet comme celui j'ai indiqué
tout à l'heure sur la combraille avec
trois communes
il vaut mieux payer un chef de projet à
l'échelle de l'intercommunalité et
ensuite voire ponctuellement sur une
commune s'il ya une problématique
commerciale et ça peut c'est pas
forcément une problématique commerciale
sa patte une problématique d'habitat
auquel cas si tout cela est cumulable
c'est à dire que le tout c'est de mettre
en relation par exemple avec l' agence
nationale d'amélioration de l'habitat là
où les collectivités concernées pour
faire en sorte que le projet soit un
projet qui monte en gamme et toutes les
aides d'état qui sont possibles sont
cumulables avec ce dispositif
donc on est vraiment sur une
dynamisation qui à mon avis on a
énormément de sens au regard de ce que
sont les bois je connais quand même bien
la ruralité
alors on va dire que je connais mieux en
montagne que dans la plaine mais c'est
pas complètement faux mais le bourg
centre c'est quand même le lieu de la
vie qui fait que si la vie par du bourg
centre c'est l'intégralité de
l'intercommunalité qui disparaît voilà
donc je crois que ce programme est
vraiment dédié pour revitaliser des
zones qui jusqu'à présent
quelquefois en vue partir tous les
commerces les habitants et autriche il
faut revitaliser je vais le dire on va
parler d'un sujet dont il a été beaucoup
question lors de ce comité
interministériel c'est la santé oui
c'est un enjeu de l'agenda rural qui est
important les déserts médicaux
où en est-on au niveau du déploiement de
la télémédecine dans les zones sous
denses et recrutement de médecins
salariés
alors justement sur cette question qui
est extrêmement importante
on va passer à la vitesse supérieure
vous savez que
pour l'implantation de médecins en zones
sous denses
bon les 600 médecins qui devait
s'implanter on n'a pas arriver à la
jauge qui est la jauge maximale pour
plusieurs raisons la première raison je
pense que les ars en ce moment vous
comprendrez qu'il ya un peu d'autres
chats à fouetter
compte tenu de la pandémie mais au delà
c'est pas non plus toujours le métier
des ars c'est la raison pour laquelle
avec jacqueline gourault dans la loi 3d
on est en train de voir comment donner
de nouvelles compétences je pense
notamment au département à partir
d'expérimentations qui sont extrêmement
intéressante dans le puy de dôme par
exemple en saône et loire où les
territoires ont quand même réinventer
les choses c'est un espèce de
dispensaires département de salles avec
des médecins que l'on place sur les
territoires là où il ya effectivement
une zone soudan c'est une problématique
importante postes qui peuvent se
transformer en médecine libérale s'il ya
une solvabilité d'ailleurs de cette
plantation et je crois qu'il vaut mieux
être dans des logiques ou c'est une
collectivité de proximité qui recrutent
et qui accueille en plus parce qu'elle a
toutes les fonctions d'accueil assez
classique de ses médecins
donc c'est un élément de la loi 3d que
nous allons mettre en oeuvre avec
l'accord du ministère bien évidemment de
la santé pour que puissent mieux
déployer ses 600 médecins voire plus
d'ailleurs parce que les initiatives
entre nous soit dit du puy de dôme ou de
saône et loire ce sont en fait même en
dehors de tout cela donc moi je suis je
suis très pro initiatives locales mais
il ya des freins juridiques
c'est à nous d'élever il vaut mieux que
ça marche dans ce sens là c'est à dire
une expérimentation locale ou envoient
des freins juridiques et on se dit levon
les frais juridiques dans la loi plutôt
que de dire voilà la loi et voilà ce qui
est bon pour vous prenez
c'est à dire manger dans tous mais ça ne
marche pas forcément alors justement
autre initiative c'est une demande qui
émane des territoires elle est portée
par michel fournier il attend la mise à
disposition d'un terne qu'ils fassent
des stages obligatoires en secteur
soudan c'est ce que c'est toujours une
priorité c'est que c'est la priorité
même parce que ça là où ça a été fait
michel fournier a entièrement raison de
le souligner ça bien fait je n'ai le
président de l'association des maires
absolument le nouveau président
puisqu'il a succédé à vanik berberian il
y a
samedi dernier donc c'est très récent
mais je crois que sur ces choses ces
éléments là nous on suit je dirais les
politiques publiques du ministère de la
santé mais on les a un petit peu
anticipé et on a demandé aux ministères
de la santé de maintenir un système qui
est un système qui favorise
financièrement pour est très claire le
fait d'être dans une maison de santé par
exemple est maître de stage c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui ait un référent des chu et
qui permet d'accueillir ce type de
stagiaires internes qui en plus ensuite
regarde si oui ou non il se sent bien
dans l'espace rural où il est moi je les
fais en tant que présidents
d'intercommunalités en tant que maire il
fallait quand même que les gens de tests
savez quand vous habitez dans les alpes
vous arrivez en était tout est beau il
fait chaud il ya des touristes puis on
arrive en octobre il fait moins de 15
bon c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
pour peu qu'on soient mariés ou en
couple et que on est pas la même vision
des choses
tout le monde n'est pas à la fois
médecin et guides de haute montagne donc
donc on est arrivés grâce à ces stages à
faire en sorte d'avoir un vivier déjà
deux remplaçants qui sait que ce qui est
extrêmement important et un vivier de
remplaçants y compris j'allais dire
lorsque les médecins partent à la
retraite
donc oui c'est un truc qu'il faut
favoriser et il faut aussi favoriser des
solutions alternatives et le ségur de la
santé à prolonger des mesures qui nous
sommes importantes par exemple certains
actes médicaux fait part des professions
paramédicales notamment je pense aux
infirmières qui sont très présentes sur
le territoire
c'était important de le prolonger tout
comme la parliez tout à l'heure de la
télémédecine le fait de rembourser les
actes de télémédecine qui étaient là
aussi importante de prolonger parce que
je crois que dans le milieu rural c'est
justement je dirais important et où en
dehors de la pandémie et dernière
question joël giraud malheureusement le
temps file il nous reste une minute sur
le numérique un bon il a été beaucoup
question dans ce comité
oui voilà partir d'aujourd'hui les
opérateurs sont autorisés à allumer
leurs antennes 5 gr le gouvernement
défend cette technologie elle fait débat
qu'est ce qui va se passer dans les
zones rurales qu'elle déploie dans les
zones rurales ans déjà il faut pas
oublier qu'il faut finir la 4g alors la
4g on a beaucoup progressé on est
effectivement sur deux ans à des taux de
couverture qui sont améliorées
elle est de presque 10 points sur quinze
cantons concerne un seul opérateur mais
alors de 30 points lorsqu'on a les
quatre opérateurs donc c'est quand même
quelque chose qui a été considérablement
améliorée et on a une politique qui une
politique de couverture cible et c'est à
dire qu'on fait remonter la réalité de
des zones où il ya toujours des zones
blanches ou en vo j'en ai même fait
remonter qui est que les élus locaux
n'avaient pas fait remonter parce que je
suis retrouvé dans un endroit eu une
grosse entreprise en plein milieu du
département de l'allier et il y avait ni
le téléphone n'y a rien il y avait à la
limite du satellitaire à des prix
prohibitifs
donc il s'agit de remonter ensuite on
rentre en couverture ciblées et là on
prend des arrêtés il ya du en corée en
octobre pour mettre des pylônes de
couverture et la 5g
elle est aussi importante je veux citer
le cas de cette entreprise qui est une
entreprise qui fait de l'export enfin
qu'il ya des filiales à l'étranger et
autres et la sagesse est fait pour
transmettre des grosses donner des
données paquet importante est bien le
premier ni s'est exprimé on a eu une
interministérielle avec cédric haut avec
jacqueline gourault et le premier
ministre pour finir et guéridons que
nous avons décidé que le la 5g ne devait
pas être de exclusive je dirais du
territoire où on est il y en aura en
zone rurale il y aura des
expérimentations que le premier ministre
a annoncé d'ailleurs au congrès des élus
de montagne en montagne parce que en
bout de valve et quelquefois c'est là où
vous avez la grosse station c'est là
vous avez les gros besoins et on va
parler de ce sujet dans le club des
territoires et de la ruralité aussi ce
sont les deux thèmes du club merci
beaucoup merci algéro d'avoir été avec
nous regarde la une de l'écho
républicain sébastien la parole aux
amazones c'est à la une de votre journal
aujourd'hui merci d'avoir été avec
tension parce que tu te lèves des
territoires la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle
[Musique]